[Music]
Jordan thanks for joining me here unless
a sexual cafe here's someone who takes
the way you live your life your
lifestyle very seriously don't you yes
I'm very particular about the way I live
my life and the products I use right
you're very particular also about the
way you dress you always wear the same
thing you're always wearing black pants
and a dark shirt every day you come to
work you're dressed like a street
magician I know what works for me I
think if you passed away tomorrow you'd
be wearing this in your casket and I'd
be the only guy there look at a product
well the product I wanted to talk about
is preparation age toda Buhl's
hemorrhoidal relief wipes before you
begin let me make it clear again I
didn't tell you to choose this product I
asked you to just pick products that you
wanted to promote and your choosing
preparation age totals bam all right
amazing go for it why I personally don't
suffer from inflamed hemorrhoids however
I still use this product quite often and
I think every American should the bidet
is not commonly used in the United
States and there's a myth that dry
toilet paper does an adequate job there
are a select few people that realized
that wet wipes at home are a much better
option and there are many products such
as this one also from preparation-h
which are moistened wipes that do a far
better job and dry toilet paper alone
tell us why preparation-h is better for
cleaning what area and how does it clean
better go you want me to say anus
okay he said that like it was the
password to a sex club I carry one of
these with me at all times mm-hmm
they're individually wrapped as you can
see here please very easy to transport
in one's pocket okay well you oh you're
putting that in your back pocket that's
you're shoving that up your ass are you
embarrassed at all when you walk into a
bathroom in a public place and you're
holding this and everyone knows that you
brought your own moist wipe your bum bum
with you call it bum bum no pretty
follow buttocks you use this product you
enjoy this product and you encourage
others to use it as well this product
has gotten me out of many jams and I
recommend that every American carry out
dams
we're not talking about it's one thing
to say it's really good that I have an
emergency flare in the back of my car
cuz it got me out of a jam it's really
good that I have mace in my pocket cuz
it got me out of a jam why does a moist
towelette the preparation H on it for
your buttocks get you out of it look
like jammer use this product more than
you willed an emergency flare and
secondly I think everyone's encountered
situations where they found the quality
and/or quantity of toilet paper avail to
them in a public space was inadequate
okay I believe every American should
carry one of these with them at all
times what about people in other
countries there's no need if you're in a
country that commonly features the day
why don't you get it the day you want to
get a bidet in your apartment it's
possible I will you think you'd get a
bidet I've been looking into the
plumbing requirements I bet you have
alright well the product is
preparation-h becomes either in this
packet right here correct for home use
for home use and this packet which are
totals correct and you say you do not
have hemorrhoids
everyone has hemorrhoids I do not have
inflamed hemorrhoids also known as piles
trick question and he wiggled his way
out of it very nice you're not getting
paid then he'd do stress you're not
getting paid to this endorsement I know
I'm not I'm only getting paid in the
cleanliness that I achieved in that area
anus freak
complete freak
[Applause]
you